police on Hawaii's Big Island stepped-up
evacuations overnight after two new
volcanic cracks opened up in the ground
there are now 14 active fissures from
the Kilauea volcano officials are
worried that more could begin spilling
lava at any moment now Carter Evans is
at the emergency command post that's in
Palau oh ha ha ha there you go well
thank you
oh-hoo Hawaii Carter good morning good
morning
this emergency is far from over just
what many thought the volcanic activity
had subsided these new fissures were a
reminder that these eruptions are as
unpredictable as they are dangerous
newly released government video showed
just how active these volcanic fissures
remain almost a week after the first
eruption this view inside the volcano
shows the bubbling lava lake which is
draining downhill into underground
rivers of molten rock there's still a
lot of magma that could be moving down
the rift zone so this isn't over this is
not over on Tuesday two new fissures
open they were both in line with the 12
already existing eruptions in the
hard-hit Leilani Estates neighborhood
this is where the lava is going to break
to the surface and so we may see
fissures next to each other or extending
from another one so yeah there's really
no way to know how long this could go
wrong this video shows one of the new
fissures emitting clouds of toxic smoke
members of the Hawaii Army National
Guard ward gas masks to measure the
area's sulfur dioxide levels which are
still dangerously high so their quality
there is well above what we would allow
the public to we would not make a
recommendation for the public to be in
that area Michael Hale lost his home of
18 years to the lava flow this is where
you're sleeping he's now living out of
his van his few remaining possessions in
a tent nearby the battery was dead on
his Ford Mustang and he had no time to
jumpstart it before it was enveloped by
lava for me the the Mustang was one
thing but the r2d2 mailbox
my daughter built that and gave it to me
on a Christmas morning as a surprise so
you know a little more sentimental value
leilani estates at a neighboring
community had been under mandatory
evacuation since last week but because
of the dangerous gases coming from these
new fissures emergency management sent
out a cell phone alert last night
warning any stragglers to leave
immediately Nora yeah an important
warning there Carter Evans in Hawaii you
think about the damage but also just the
memories you know the memories that are
destroyed it shows you it's not the big
inexpensive stuff because you can always
replace that it's a personal stuff that
someone made for you that you can't
replace actually our 292 mailbox